a massive earthquake knocks you off your
feet
there's a blinding flash of light and
then you see a tsunami of lava rising on
the horizon
a nuclear reaction has gone off the
rails
and earth's atmosphere is on fire
how long would it be before you exploded
into flames
what would happen to our land and oceans
[Music]
and where could you hide to survive this
hellfire
[Music]
this is what if and here's what would
happen if earth's atmosphere ignited
tomorrow
when you combine two light nuclei to
form a single heavier nucleus
you get what we call a fusion reaction
and if these nuclei happen to be
isotopes of hydrogen you'd create the
kind of energy that powers the sun and
other stars
today six countries have the recipe to
cook up a fusion reaction and make
hydrogen bombs
what would happen if a massive bomb like
that
lit up our atmosphere
of course the most destructive element
at work in our world is climate change
but thankfully there's a company
fighting this threat so let's thank the
sponsor of today's video climb works for
creating the technology we need to
preserve our planet klimworx uses direct
air capture technology to remove carbon
dioxide from the air storing it
underground permanently for millennia
and now this gas can never contribute to
global warming again
now is the time to step up and reverse
the damage of climate change and with
climax i know i can help create a better
earth for my kids and their future and
great news right now you can give the
gift of carbon dioxide removal to your
family and friends for the holiday
season a sustainable eco-friendly gift
that also helps our planet the first 100
people to use the code what if 10 will
receive 10 percent off their first
purchase act now because this code is
only valid till the end of the year head
to gift.climworks.com
if to give the gift of carbon dioxide
removal this holiday season hey if we
clean our air
maybe we can stop this explosion from
ever happening
the most efficient reaction is one
between two isotopes of hydrogen
deuterium and tritium
it generates more energy at lower
temperatures
but fusion like that
needs temperatures of about 100 million
degrees
that's about seven times hotter than the
center of the sun
okay let's say you managed to create
those conditions and line up the exact
amount of fuel needed to set the
atmosphere on fire
what sort of infernal nightmare would
you be in for
first forget any fire drills you've ever
done
this would be the mother of all
firestorms
one you can't get away from because
well the atmosphere is everywhere
plants buildings and people
would ignite instantly
if by some miracle you didn't
you would see some pretty awesome stuff
at 1510 degrees steel would begin to
melt
skyscrapers and bridges would ooze
molten steel
at 1700 degrees deserts would melt and
sand would turn into glass
you'd lose all oceans entirely as the
hydrogen in them would feed the fusion
reaction
but taking in the sights and sounds
might not be on the top of your mind
couldn't you just hide deep underground
and wait it out
well no
at about 1300 degrees all rock would
start to melt
if the ignition lasted long enough earth
might become a lava world hot like
mercury
maybe you're an astronaut exploring a
galaxy far far away while the earth
burned
what would you come back to
a desolate lifeless world of molten lava
is all that would be left
you'd have to get used to living in a
radioactive world where you'd sound
funny when you speak
that's because with all the hydrogen
having fused
earth's atmosphere would now have helium
[Applause]
[Laughter]
but you'd stop laughing soon enough
your lungs would fill up with helium
pretty quickly because it's heavier than
oxygen and then
you would choke and die
luckily nature runs a very tight ship
and you wouldn't find enough materials
on earth to set the atmosphere on fire
our oceans only have about 0.16
deuterium and it was all created during
the big bang
so it's not exactly renewable
protium is a lot easier to find but
needs impossibly higher temperatures to
fuse
that leaves you with a choice between
going on an extraterrestrial bounty hunt
for more deuterium or coaxing protium to
defy the laws of physics
i mean unless of course you find a way
to boil the oceans to 100 million
degrees
besides you wouldn't want to launch
nuclear weapons all over the planet to
perform this dangerous experiment
that might just set off world war three
and what happens then
well
that's a story
or another what if